hallo mein name ist luca unter meinem
letzten rätsel test chris what ever
video haben wir sehr viele von euch
geschrieben dass ich doch mal die apple
reynaud austesten soll und ihr seht ihr
schon dass es das rätsel nummer 1 finde
die größte
man denkt vettel aber nur weil er groß
gemacht bildschirm
klicke ich jetzt einfach mal auf die
melone und das ist auch richtig
nobelpreis kopf titel nummer zwei wie
viele enten 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
aber du kleiner pisser und da haben wir
neun enten genau das ist jetzt auch
richtig dass hammer das ist mir dann
immer so blöd da fühle ich mich echt
gewährt halt die fresse du laufen wer
ist das rätsel wer ist der größte wir
haben einen elefanten einen hund einen
hamster eine giraffe selbstverständlich
die gier
ok
vielleicht die nach gewichts dann
wir haben nun die sonne daumen klickt
man auf die sonne drauf das ist
natürlich richtig wieder applaus hier
für mich weiter geht's kannst du den
unterschied herausfinden
die sehen alle exakte gleich aus die
auch nicht dies ist auch nicht
die nicht
die auch nicht
[Musik]
das ändert jetzt natürlich alles wir
können nicht
wir können nicht nur klicken sondern
auch weil pin- und hin und her vision
von daher welche klaue endet der
ausgestreckten klau der katze da die
wahrscheinlich weder bislang nämlich die
eigene okay das geht nicht die anderen
[Applaus]
ein problem meist die gleichwertig wie
viele dreiecke gibt es in einem pentagon
das weiß ich das sind 12
das habe ich irgendwann mal gelernt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte sagen ich bin schlau aber
jeder weiß
stimmt finde das größte feuer also wie
ich diese app hersteller kenne ist sie
irgendwo du
[Musik]
ach so ich dachte wie lautet die nummer
unter dem geparkten auto ich glaube das
kenne ich nämlich auch das muss man auf
den kopf halten und dann haben wir 0 2
78 mir das also ihr müsst euch echt um
mich zu kämpfen müsst ihr euch etwas
besseres einfallen lassen welche
bewertung würdest du diesem spiel geben
ich klicke einfach mal auf volle
punktzahl es natürlich auch richtig nee
ich will hier nicht bewerten
weiter gehts wecke die eule auf nicht
die sonne gleich irgendwie die sonne
kann nicht verschieben kann ich die
sonne auf jetzt auch noch die gebäude
es muss nacht werden
in island sind nachttiere von daher hab
ich die sonne einfach mal nach unten nee
das geht nicht zusammen
[Musik]
marvin braucht lehrer oder so wenn einer
krank ist finde etwas das man nicht
essen kann wir haben eine melone wir
haben pommes wir haben ein eis und wir
haben ein huhn mit eiern
wir können das einfach mal wieder ein
bisschen und herzchen du musst das spiel
gewinnen
sony hat die kreuze und ich habe die
kreise ich packe einfach mal hier einen
hin das geht nicht hier das geht auch
nicht
das geht auch nicht er war das ja
menschlich dass man dann auch mal
vielleicht was nicht so richtig direkt
weiß nie was ist das hier tipps wir
brauchen tipps
ich brauche ein tipp jetzt muss ich mich
in der werbung angucken
nachdem ich gerade fünf euro bezahlt
habe menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßen er wird auf jeden fall eine von
diesen glühbirnen bekommen und könnte
jetzt hier draufklicken benutze zwei
finger um das ohr gleichzeitig zu füllen
mache es der reihe nach um das
gleichzeitig
[Musik]
finde die dunkelste farbe auf dem
bildschirm das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
nicht dass hier sondern irgendwie hier
oben gehirn schraube ist bei mir
komplett komplett gordon klicken wir
auch weiter zähle die anzahl der haare
[Musik]
ich bin gerade einfach alle möglichen
zahlen durchgegangen aber warum denn 3
wenn ihr uns wissen schreibt zwar gerne
in die kommentare aber warum werden drei
hilft dem entlein wasser zu trinken
[Musik]
ich sags mal so
in dem raum mit mehreren
wissenschaftlern wär ich schalte kannst
du dieses problem lösen natürlich kann
ich das problem lösen eins plus 0,7 plus
0 32
würde man jetzt vermuten muss ich da ist
an zeichnen
machen
kannst du etwas essbares finden also wir
müssen wahrscheinlich wieder irgendwas
hier rum ziehen oder wir müssen wir
müssen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war
der kleine elefant ist so einsam also ja
das ist ja das ist sehr blöd
nee ich will mir nicht diese komische
fischbuch hier runterladen halte lange
gedrückt um den elefanten für die blitz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz kurz davor hat so seine zugspitze
aus dem boden zu reißen stelle die
giraffe in den kühlschrank da jeder
versteht
im schrank richtig giraffe gedrückt
halten bringt auch wieder nichts drehen
kann ich hier nichts wenn du drei münzen
in die sparbüchse steckst wie viele
münzen hat es jetzt also ich stelle mal
123 rein natürlich hat das ding jetzt
drei münzen allerdings das ist natürlich
falsch wie viele münzen hat es jetzt 0
auch falsch drei wochen später
[Musik]
es hat 13
erzählen bin ich zu dumm zum zählen
das sind doch 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 13
14 15
da hab ich nicht vertan so hungrig macht
etwas zu essen ich bin darauf zieht also
die häuser kann man ja augenscheinlich
schon mal nicht essen
es hat wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit der
wolke hier zu tun das kann's ja auch
nicht essen ein spiegelei wie viele
schnitte brauchst du mindestens um einen
kreis in acht gleiche teile zu schneiden
man braucht vier mindestens mindestens
einen dann
[Musik]
bei jedem rätsel wenn ich das geschafft
habe bin ich ihn wieder nach froh aber
irgendwie bin ich auch extrem genervt
finde die regel heraus und schreibe die
antwort auf also da wir haben fünf
kreise das ist ein kreis vier kreise
plus allerdings eins dass ein ding ist
ne eins dann haben wir alle
dann
das macht ja vorn und hinten
denn
[Musik]
ja ich gehe zum ausgang steht hier jetzt
ich kann mich hier einfach so rum
bewegen das ist ja warte man das ist ja
dass da komme ich gar nicht raus oder
kam das ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr also das ist richtig
frech das ist also das sind jetzt
wirklich eine andere liga die wir jetzt
hier erreicht haben
wenn das so die lösung ist ne also dann
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass sich niemand einen
zweiten teil von dieser gewünscht an der
stelle des heutigen das allerdings ob
entweder lieben freunde wenn euch
breakout mit mir mit luca ein stein
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier dauernd
schreibt in die kommentare
ob ihr bock auf einen zweiten teil davon
hätte wenn ihr den man nicht verpassen
wollt könnt ihr hier auf den smiley
draufklicken damit abonniert in dem ich
meinen canalis ist kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr also mach das
mal
und hier ist ein video was ich gerade
auf meinem 2 kanal hochgeladen habe und
zwar ist es eine challenge das video ist
nämlich vorbei sobald katja das wort ist
sagt also liegt das an